back-to-back playing fo rizzle again
okay let's see what we get we don't pass
main line now with a form okay oh my now
I've totally forgotten this hmm I think
it shows some Bishop g4 but I absolutely
don't remember the details absolutely
forgot I forgot everything ok let's get
this in if he plays age 3 i think i'll
yeah i think i'll just go back on age 5
this is just offside after 92f 1g3 ok
yep maybe I've lost if I probably lost
some tempo here maybe is wrong very
likely I've lost some tempo but i'm not
sure how how important that is it's a
fairly em slow kind of position
you how to how to do that you will get
the bishop to be three I think this is
kind of clear I was thinking h6 but
maybe that that weekend's f5 quite a bit
H Sigma should be six was my idea hmm
but it's not ideal can also start with
this okay Bishop f F F ADA is Bishop g5
so i go here Bishop f8b should be six
okay maybe it's got ya this one but I
should be able to play we should be six
King h7 g6 Queen f3 though yea my queen
on a a damn this is a bit of an issue
definitely an issue hmm okay
I wonder if c4 is an action is an idea
here actually c4 takes it tonight a five
I think I'll do that it is probably
helping me get something going here
myself I mean also blocking this Bishop
off I wonder tonight a five maybe and
then take it unsure but should be 6e
might take b5 him so I have to do this
anyway yeah and now maybe just take with
the night
the night is blocking this diagonal the
hof seven at least if he goes Bishop b3
again that's not all that terrible okay
so this one trying to play g6 looks a
bit scary on that diagonal but I don't
don't see anything bad happening right
now yeah okay maybe he's switching
yessum attention to the D pawn bishop a3
is something that is now on the agenda
that's bad
poor that's not great at all Bishop a
three-night c8 that looks pretty awful
but maybe if i can if i can send the
light bag with g6 and he has to retreat
i mean i'm not sure he has but if this
is the case that you would retreat then
it's not so bad but I definitely have
misplayed dad Bishop d3 maybe this okay
b5 hangs but okay if I go g6 now am i
threatening to take it i think i do i
have to have to check here because of
the diagonal there are cases where you
can just allow the capture with white
but it doesn't feel like this is the
case here I simply didn't see that ah
Wow assembly I simply did not see this
possibility what spot that it was that
was on wow that's pretty bad words will
seem not sure how easy this is to
convert
ok some I go look a eight Bishop am
Bishop d3 probably
okay um time morning
yeah i was thinking night of six but to
tell you can go f3m and he's got
everything quite quite neatly covered
okay 596 is not the terrible check check
check check
yeah this problem is still very easy
when I was born son Jack too strong
check I don't have one two three okay
yeah I was pretty stupid black resigns I
just I just did not see that the six was
was hanging I mean I'm under pressure
there but I don't have to blunder the
pawn so and I didn't think it's all that
clear to be honest but probably it was
and I don't get to get enough counter
play them yeah so that wasn't all that
great I got under pressure here still
thought it should be possible to to have
a playable position but that Bishop a
three that was a little bit a little bit
too much yeah the computer wants to take
with the pawn that it looked too strange
to me to be honest to talk to strange
but it has one point yeah the bishop
here now is not coming to a three and
this may be the most important point the
engine is not really all that
pessimistic here it gives white 0.3
nothing special but when is definitely
I'm better here but it is maybe I'm not
all that bad yeah this looks this looks
very strange for me the engine is not
even taking 106 playing playing
playing it back but I don't think I can
vastly improve on that Luke aid is
probably bad i am f 398 back it's still
it's still not that easy to convert
maybe and the pawns are not going
forward all that quickly but this is of
course not a position you want to be in
in the first place probably I'm didn't
play this setup to too well and that's
normal move as it's the typical thing is
that often the computer finds
technically based resources that a human
has problems to find here the engine
gives screen 85 and gives an advantage
to black but this is not easy to see you
have a Thetis 94 because of that rook
hanging and this is extremely annoying
for white because this is a fork on on
both pieces what actually has to play
green back to d1 so green efi basically
refutes White's play but this is not the
kind of movie would you see I mean not
not with seconds you play a normal move
it's even welling in an actual game you
should see it but Queen D 1 and then
before yeah and the computer gives like
a slight edge I don't know about that
but I mean if he has to go back with the
Queen then it's a clear that this is a
that this was not working basically but
this is not something I mean 23 is a
completely normal end and good looking
move and clean air five is a very tough
resource to see interesting interesting
though based on that on those
to pieces ok guys thanks for watching